you are a new dad correct yes I am how
recently well 14 months you 14-mile
congratulations how is it is it hard to
be why not is it hard to be on the road
you're a road comic you're very
successful you're shooting a show all
over the country is it is it difficult
well it's I mean you want to be home
with your family you know so like my
wife sometimes she and my baby his
name's Reed
they'll come with us maybe to a city and
he loves vodka so it's great but like
you know you get into a plane with a kid
when you see a person with a kid you're
like oh god here comes the kid that's
gonna be crying and squawking so I look
at my wife I'm like let me let me set
the vibe here you know what I mean she's
like what are you doing relax like will
you relax
I got this good way to talk to her yeah
you know I mean marriage and so I go to
the Stewart's I go hate you mind
grabbing the overhead and she goes oh
yeah and I got my son like this and then
I just take him I go thanks so much and
I go to put him up and everyone round is
laughing I'm like now we're in yeah he
starts crying like dad that kids funny
[Laughter]
and you're taking you're using him as a
comedy prop basically yeah he's like I'm
a prop comic now you know I mean you got
to get the comedy where you can come I
can't write jokes yeah yeah you know
they're only that small for so long and
you gotta get you took a picture what is
that like yeah I think that you guys
have I took a you know I like to do
funny things with them and so I took
this picture I don't you can you show it
yeah there it is that's you like just
getting ready for dinner hope very nice
come on you wouldn't to eat that kid cuz
being a dad come easily to you is it
something that comes naturally did you
always want to be a dad I always want to
be this I mean well here's the deal 5th
grade like in the back a notebook you'd
have like Roger Clemens number 1 yeah
yeah well like I love Tracy Stewart
whatever I had kids names like list boys
girls like I wouldn't need my kid Nolan
you really you really in fifth grade
we're dreaming about having great oh
yeah and so now I'm like just can't I
mean I love it I can't wait it like I
spoke at a dad conference 14 months
spoken to dad conference no big deal
right went in with a list I gave a top
10 list of like top 10 things I wanted
with my kid sure teach him how to ride a
bike got to do it yeah give him money
for his first date got to do
right give him a beer before he's 21
come on you know the motive bonding yeah
and you know in the comedian me number
10 my favorite one I just said live
above his garage when his mother dies if
he explained someone's gonna die first I
have longevity in my family I'm gonna be
around so you've talked about this with
your wife and she's she understands yeah
I mean she knows it's inevitable I'll be
above the garage I'll come down like in
my underwear with hey what are you doing
at 90 you're gonna really last that long
I'm going I'm going 100 I got I love
that you get to decide yeah well CeeLo
was 102 on thiru 100 on Tygart 98 and my
Nana god bless her she died really young
she was 88 wow that's a that should get
a better laugh than that I like your
style hey yeah grandmothers are always
funny hey thanks for watching be sure to
click subscribe to see even more great
Conan clips you may now return to your
pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography